my brother chose to end his life by  suicide and it deeply impacted myself  and my parents and when i look back you  know my thoughts about myself and  whether the world was safe enough and i  could go make something of myself in it  had really shifted right you know i  really didn't have a knowledge of like  oh you think about yourself differently  or you have an internal dialogue that's  built around shame now and built around  shock and did you know i needed help  then and there's no  shame to that right in a sense right  like trauma makes us want to feel  ashamed so that we hide but we we  absolutely need help if it rises to the  point where we're not sleeping well  we're depressed we can't get it out of  our minds you know if one hurts one's  knee or you know one has a problem in  their lungs like we go see  people to help us if trauma rises to the  level of overwhelming our coping skills  then our brain function changes and we  can't just think our way into changing  that back